and several spots open for the clark  county school board of trustees these  are nonpartisan races which means that  if no one gets the 50 percent the top  two vote getters will face each other on  the ballot in november and it is a tight  race let's start with district d  stephen conger now has a slim lead over  irene cepeda who's the incumbent as for  district f irene bustamante a former  nevada assemblywoman is a head of  incumbent danielle four 21 to 18 percent  they'll likely be facing each other in  november as well and finally for  district g  linda cavazos the only one of the  incumbents in the lead in her race and  that'll also go to a runoff against greg  wieman